congratulations irina this was a great
performance thank you alejandro
true arena congratulations what an
amazing tournament for you an amazing
couple of weeks here in saint louis
first of all what does it mean to be
the first champion of the american cup
oh i'm very you know honored to win this
title of this inaugural tournament
um you know especially like i've been
playing chess my whole life and finally
there's a tournament called the american
cup so it's quite nice to win it
um yeah it was i mean i have to say i
love this format i hope that the
tournament continues um really
innovative i mean i don't think in the
chess world there's ever been a double
knockout at least not that i can
remember i think it's been really
exciting for the fans
um of course you know i tried to keep
the excitement down to minimum in my
matches like i don't i didn't play any
playoffs and that was certainly um i
think to my advantage
um
but yeah i look forward to playing again
it seemed like smooth sailing all
throughout the event you kept it only in
classical time controls did you feel at
any point that you were in danger of
maybe not making it or being relegated
to the elimination bracket well
definitely the the toughest point in my
tournament um was the match against
begin
you know there was of course a point in
that first game where i knew i could
lose
things were going very badly at some
point towards the end um you know once i
got past that okay there was still a
second game that was quite difficult as
well i think once i got past that match
you know things were
much more under control
um yeah you know on the surface it does
look very smooth yeah i know but you
can't but you know underneath there's
like so much preparation and you know
like thinking about what you're gonna
play there's definitely um there's
definitely effort beneath the surface
tell us a little bit about that
elaborate because it does for us at
least it felt like you were just in the
zone all the time every single day you
uh played precise you played calm chess
as well what was happening behind closed
doors yeah i mean nothing nothing too
exciting but you know um i think like
for me this tournament you know the
dates of this tournament were a little
bit challenging you know because they
were
basically on
uh began the holy week and this is like
normally a week i would spend a lot of
time in church and i still tried to do
that um
you know during that whole first week
and so that was a little hard you know
because you're balancing like the
tournaments you're going to church every
evening
and you know it kind of cuts into your
preparation and your rest and everything
but at the same time you know i felt
like okay i need to do that i need to do
my best in both directions so for me the
first week was the hardest like once i
got past that um you know then things
were more clear
thank you and arena as far as today's uh
game went i i couldn't imagine it would
have been
uh
better scripted for you the opening is
something you're very familiar with have
a great deal of experience against
isolated queen pawns there was never any
great dangers to your king and
everything was a very smooth game yeah
you know again you know opening
preparation does matter a lot you know
and you have to
you have to use all your experience and
you got to find those places where it's
going to be kind of uncomfortable for
your opponents and so that's something
that's a big part of my overall
strategies like i'm always trying to
find that spot where my opponents are
not going to be so
comfortable and that spot turned out to
be this e6 line of the of the i don't
know the semislav i guess you called
that and you know at some point last
night i started looking at the games i
was like obviously i'm not going to
repeat knight d7 um as we had in the
first game that was fine for one game
but that's a line where white can
certainly uh fight for an advantage so i
had to find something else and then i
got this idea and you know my coach was
like how did you come up with that such
a good idea you know
yes nice
well congratulations i'm sorry to
interrupt you but we do have one uh
remaining game and the players are
getting into uh time trouble so rather
than
uh i was just going to ask you did you
do do you look at the other game while
you're playing like you just kind of go
over there yeah very little very little
okay but it kind of feels like in a way
this game is a little similar to their
game yesterday isn't it there's
something that looks like they're in
this end game again there's bishop on
the board yeah
your need your take i mean obviously
white for
white's doing really really well
you think
it's a it's a position that fabi can
bring home and win
yeah i think there's a good chance i
mean you know the bishop is definitely
stronger
yeah stronger than the knights and yeah
black has always this problem with the e
pawn and then the a pawn i guess as well
exactly exactly
well arena not only are you 25 000
richer but you're going to get a very 30
30 30 000 because of the uh 5 000 bonus
but you're going to get a very nice uh i
think a little bling bling oh that
sounds good he's very very very good uh
we will see you later i'll see you later
thank you guys absolutely thank you
congratulations irena certainly let's
just jump straight into the game because